so december's playstation plus games
have been made official but it's not
exactly what the rumors claimed we're
gonna talk about that some delays and
more
so the rumors were true this month's
playstation plus games include mortal
shell
lego dc super villains and godfall
however it's not the full version of the
game instead playstation plus members
can expect to play godfall challenger
edition this version of the game allows
players to jump straight to max level
and experience godfall's end game modes
lightbringer dreamstones and ascended
tower of trials so i'm slightly on the
fence with this offering on one hand
it's a free game can't really complain
about that and i mean it does seem like
it could be a good way for people to
taste godfall but
to start us from end game like you could
have given us the base game but without
the dlc or something it's just
i don't know it seems like a weird
decision
let me know what you think in the
comments i'm just sitting here thinking
about it let's move on to the next story
oh but first it's important to note that
the same three psvr games from november
are staying free in december and this
includes the persistence the walking
dead saints and sinners and until you
fall so if you haven't grabbed them go
ahead and grab them even if you don't
have vr get them just in case you get
playstation vr in the future boom you
got three games there already to play
now moving on to grand theft auto the
trilogy the definitive edition because
the physical editions have been delayed
announced in a tweet yesterday rockstar
shared the physical ps4 xbox one and
xbox series x and s versions of grand
theft auto the trilogy will now release
on december 17th while the nintendo
switch version of the game will launch
sometime during early 2022. all physical
editions were originally scheduled for a
december 7th release
and in other news the original titanfall
is no longer available for sale the game
has been removed from storefronts
starting today and will be removed from
subscription services on march 1 2022.
developer respawn announced the news via
twitter and said while the xbox one
launch title will no longer be available
for purchase servers for the original
titanfall will remain online so that
players who already own the game can
continue playing the game is currently
available via ea play which is also
included as a part of xbox game pass pc
and ultimate respawn didn't elaborate on
why the decision was being made to pull
the game from storefronts but it did
reassure fans that the studio is still
dedicated to the titanfall franchise so
will titanfall continue to live on in
apex legends or will we finally see a
titanfall 3
ah don't give me hope
moving right along to fall guys now
season six party spectacular is
officially live and players around the
world can now play the latest content
including new limited time events 50
tiers of rewards to unlock and a new
patch to earn exclusive costumes many
players believe that the xbox and
nintendo switch version of the battle
royale party game would also be released
alongside the update and now developer
mediatonic has addressed these rumors in
a new blog post the dev said quote
there's been a lot of speculation on
social media connecting these new
console releases to the season 6 launch
and we want to clarify that that's not
the case so no one's confused looking
for the game on these platforms thank
you for being patient with us it's one
of our top priorities in active
development and we can't wait to share
more details with you in 2022
the nintendo switch and xbox versions of
fall guys was scheduled for a summer
2021 release date however it was delayed
earlier this year with mediatonics
saying it was quote just too soon
so go ahead and hit the comment section
and talk to me about today's stories
give me some thoughts some opinions and
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]